[موسيقى]
اهلا
وسهلا خلينا ازيكم عاملين ايه انا ماسه
عندي عشر سنين والنهارده جايه اتكلم معكم
عن موضوع مهم جدا جدا جدا وهو السبب انا
عرفت الموضوع ده من ايام قليله وعايزه
احكي لكم حاجه مهمه جدا عنه
ثقه زي اكيد كلنا عارفين الشرح والنهار
اكيد مفيش حد يقدر يستغنى عن الشمس
هي بقى السكه عامله زي الشمس
هي الشمس الصغيره اللي ما استغنى عنها
هي الشجاعه اللي بتخليها تصدق في نفسها
وفي قدراتنا لما نبقى واثقين في نفسنا
اللي هيحصل نقدر نقابل تحديات كل يوم لقيت
تحديات
ها
عشان نوصل للادف اللي عايزينها هنوصل لها
عن طريق الصفه لان الثقه بتخلي الطريق ده
يكون احسن لما نفكر ان احنا قادرين نتغلب
على الصعب ونوصل نحلم بيه وحاجه تانيه انا
اتعلمتها ان مهما يكون يومك وحش انت اكيد
بتكون واثق من الايام التانيه هتكون احلى
ارتكاب تساعدنا نتعامل مع اللي حصل لينا
ونحوله للفرصه مش بس كده يعني هيبقى
واثقين في نفسنا ونقدر نكون ايجابيين
مجتهد الناس التانيه
والثقه بتساعدنا
نكون صداقات اكتر
واحكي لكم موقف حصل معايا
مره كنت خايفه اشارك فيه مسابقه السباحه
عشان كنت ببوظ التمرينات كالعاده
كن
كنت ببوظ كل تمرينه مامتي قالت لي لازم
تشتركي اكيد
واصحابي واهلي كلهم
قالوا لي لازم تشتركي لان ده
لان مسابقه دي هتزود سقطت في نفسك
مره
تخيلوا ايه اللي حصل بصت بالمركز الاول
عشان كده
بتمنى تكونوا استفدتوا في الموضوع بتاعي
شكرا
[تصفيق]